Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Ever had an experience when you shot an almost
perfect photograph of for instance, an amazing
landscape but unfortunately it was littered
with unwanted objects.
If only we had an algorithm that could perform
image inpainting, in other words, delete a
small part of an image and have it automatically
filled in!
So let's have a look at NVIDIA's AI-based
solution.
On the left, you see the white regions that
are given to the algorithm to correct, and
on the right, you see the corrected images.
So it works amazingly well, but the question
is why?
This is an established research field, so
what new can an AI-based approach bring to
the table?
Well, traditional non-learning approaches
either try to fill these holes in with other
pixels from the same image that have similar
neighborhoods, copy-paste something similar
if you will, or they try to record the distribution
of pixel colors and try to fill in something
using that knowledge.
And here comes the important part - none of
these traditional approaches have an intuitive
understanding of the contents of the image.
And that is the main value proposition of
the neural network-based learning techniques!
This work also borrows from earlier artistic
style transfer methods to make sure that not
only the content, but the style of the inpainted
regions also match the original image.
It is also remarkable that this new method
works with images that are devoid of symmetries
and can also deal with cases where we cut
out really crazy, irregularly shaped holes.
Of course, like every good piece of research
work, it has to be compared to previous algorithms.
As you can see here, the quality of different
techniques is measured against a reference
output, and it is quite clear that this new
method produces more convincing results than
its competitors.
For reference, PatchMatch is a landmark paper
from almost 10 years ago that still represents
the state of the art for non learning-based
techniques.
The paper contains a ton more of these comparisons,
so make sure to have a look.
Without doubt, this is going to be an invaluable
tool for artists in the future.
In fact, in this very series, we use Photoshop's
built-in image inpainting tool on a daily
basis, so this will make our lives much easier.
Loving it.
Also, did you know that you can get early
access to each of these videos?
If you are addicted to the series, have a
look at our Patreon page, patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers,
or just click the link in the video description.
There are also other really cool perks like
getting your name as a key supporter in the
video description, or deciding the order of
the next few episodes.
We also support cryptocurrencies, the addresses
are in the video description.
And with this, you also help us make better
videos in the future.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!